we played gta with ultra realistic
graphics and you guys loved it which is
why today we're gonna play gta 5 with
the worst graphics physically imaginable
on the count of three i want you to all
fire up gta three
oh
[Music]
what is this
where's my face where's my pants look at
the fishermen who else got pencils for
arms oh the car doesn't look as bad
oh
everybody stop what you're doing under
your keyboards is a piece of paper wait
how did this get here who put this here
on this sheet of paper is five different
incredibly hard challenges and whoever
does all five of these challenges last
has to cover themselves in fart spray
and take an uber no way please stop no
no hey if you don't want to do it get
the challenging the first challenge is
box 10 people and win all right they're
running away come here come here make
them with me
that's one i can't find someone two
these pencils baby wait are you winning
these boxes oh yeah
oh i got two i got two i got two
oh he dodged me yo i've already boxed up
20 people none
then do a stunt with a motorcycle oh i
see people
uppercut
10. okay what next do a stun with a
motorcycle where's my paper do a stunt
with a motorcycle don't run away from me
wait i'm trying to box stolen but she's
running away come back here stop running
all right i'll let you run away i gotta
find a motorcycle no no i call this the
one-two mayweather i gotta find a
motorcycle oh you're still looking for a
motorcycle don't be mean to me i'm just
trying yeah well maybe try a little bit
harder chris i have a confession i
haven't been counting how many people
i've knocked out ow uh jimmy i think
you're at one you're at one i think how
have you guys boxed so many people
already i'm having to pull people out of
their car to box them oh come on okay
why did i get arrested
get up i died oh here it is i'm going to
do a stunt jump there it is
oh i honked up i honked up i hung up i
hung up i hung up oh hey i found some
people in a box kabue here it is
i did a stunt job baby
how did i just die i can't find a
motorcycle bro i can't either sam
ew this guy's throwing up in low poly oh
no he's going through trash i don't
think i want to put my ad there that's
the ugliest building i've seen in my
life wait what the heck is this man
orange for this low quality alien carl
how did you find a motorcycle i'm not
going to like beat somebody up and then
looked over and there was a motorcycle
oh motorcycle
go how are you finding one if it makes
you feel better i'm on my way to a
tattoo parlor
on my way on a motorcycle to a tattoo
parlor let's go
pause taylor do you like honey yes i
love honey good cause now they've
sponsored the video honey is a free
browser add-on that saves you tons of
money just go to joinhoney.com
mrbeastgaming you click add to chrome
and allow extension two clicks let's say
you want to order a pepperoni pizza and
a cookie pizza they're better than you
think all you do before you check out is
hit apply coupons let honey scan the
internet for coupon codes and if it
finds a coupon code that works it will
automatically apply to your card wow it
found code 25 off and it saved me 5.82
cents on my pizza amazing isn't it get
honey it's free money the savings are
out of this world honey has found their
17 million members over 2 billion in
savings yes that's billions with the b
and honey supports all kinds of
retailers from gaming to fashion to
furniture to whatever you want see all
these retailers on the screen honey
actually works on their site if honey
interests you which it should just go to
joinhoney.com mr beastgaming it takes
two clicks to install and it's free go
to
joinhoney.comgaming and let's get back i
need a motorcycle compared to ultra
realistic gta 5 would you say this is
average well seeing as how i'm currently
in a giant thing of gravy right now for
some reason all these people are walking
through mashed potatoes right now it
looks like my game was recorded on a
potato cooking a toaster yo yo yo yo yo
spotted target spot get me that car
i just flung him off his bike i haven't
seen one really i can't even tell if i'm
wheeling because i'm in a distorted
ground i need a motorcycle oh you you no
all right i saw him i saw him i saw him
off the bike and didn't get caught
oh
oh
wait chris you can't do things that
order what you've never heard the saying
order in the court okay but that being
said i'm about to get my tattoo baby
this is the ugliest tattoo parlor i
would never trust this
oh my gosh you guys are gonna freak when
you see the tattoo welcome okay can i
freaking move maybe i think someone
needs to go sabotage carl he's a little
far ahead you know 100
i literally can't find a ramp why isn't
it working
ah
i ran into a wall that wasn't there i
say chandler can get a point if he
sabotages carl if three people say i
then we can approve it i say i no i
don't
i don't want taylor to get an extra
point though because i don't want to get
fart sprayed chris i nay guys comment
boo
boo chris no they're gonna say good job
chris cause they like carl and don't
want me to bully them comment hashtag
help chandler how about that let's help
chandler yeah well kristen want to help
you yeah you guys don't have to worry
about sabotaging me by the way the
freaking game already did excuse me i
need to get to this stunt jump okay i'll
just hit this low quality pole here i
feel like it's easier to drive when
everything's low quality i ran into an
invisible wall low quality stunt jump
i'm gonna hit that wall aren't i
is this a parking garage all right there
has to be one in here
oh okay so it said stumpjump failed i
have to complete it right yeah why is
this guy trying to fight me right now
bro i don't he looks like spaghetti my
game literally crashed dang guess you
gotta start over carl oh hey i found a
ramp i found a rap i hit a car i found
it oh dude that grass just spawned there
stunt jump failed how far do you have to
fly
oh my god i'm gonna die oh slow-mo
slow-mo
low quality slow-mo bro i just can't
believe that i literally got shut down
sound jump failed all stunt jumps
completed oh
well i said all the stunt jumps are
completed oh well then i've been sitting
there trying that's
oh all right now that i did that it's
time to go get a tattoo hey don't go to
the freaking one i went to because it
shuts down your entire game
is that one don't go anywhere
please
please chris did you find a tattoo
parlor yep i know where a tattoo parlor
is don't you guys know how to check a
map it's called a map baby it's called a
map all right tattoo parlor instant
teleport you can teleport with cabs boo
chris is teleporting it's part of the
game you can literally do it jimmy
where's the
jump my man's naked right uh what does
that say ride a block oh ride a block
like around the block oh truck truck
truck truck and it's a dump truck that's
gonna be so easy can you please tell me
where the jumps are anyone i did it i
got tattoos what's my next objective
write a block on top of a truck what
constitutes a block look at the streets
like you see how they're kind of squared
off oh i've rode like four blocks then i
thought a block was a mile i don't i
grew up in the country i don't know what
a block is wait i have to get five stars
now without a car wait you're already on
the last challenge yeah i found a
recycling truck that counts as a truck
right this is like a semi truck all
right excuse me
i need your bike okay go i can't even
there's no green light for him to go
driving on this is hard because things
just randomly pop up in front of you i
feel like it's easier to drive but
everything's low quality wait so i can't
have a car the whole time yeah the
entire time that you're getting five
stars oh my god what is happening to the
world ah
one more star come on there's
helicopters i gotta hit the helicopter
oh no i had four right when i shot it
i'm gonna need to uh hit you with a
wrench ma'am to get some stars i hope
you understand
what why did the wrench explode eat my
rpg baby super ranch
my god four stars four stars four stars
i died i died i died at four stars hey
jimmy since we're using really old
graphics i'll use a really old gun look
i have a musket get down
wait carl you also trying to get five
stars
i'll give you a hint i just mini-gunned
a bun a bus until it exploded use the
musket it's it's funnier because low
quality oh i see what you're saying a
firework launcher cowabunga gamer
wait railgun wait hold up what's this
oh okay all right all right never mind
i'm using a rail gun move out the way
i'm not trying to fight you i haven't
heard anything from chandler what's he
doing
what's a franklin tattoo where's that
you just have to get a tattoo on
franklin oh jimmy is your brain low
quality today i got a tattoo now what i
got a ride on the top of a truck for an
entire block baby
oh i got it i'm done i'm done i did it i
don't have to fart spray yes what is
this real gun all right i'm gonna help
chandler now wait why don't i get help
this was your idea jimmy keep that in
mind i'm on top of a truck i gotta ride
a block so i've been helping jimmy in my
room but carl's not been helping you at
all chandler don't even do not even
right now pencil man pencil man right
the top of trucks because a random piece
of paper under keyboard said to do it
get some speed
yeah
stunt jump come back
all right it's been a block now my fifth
and final challenge is get five stars
without a car
i keep dying don't sprint in there too
hard or you'll knock him over and it'll
make him mad so just walk casually in
there all right torso yeah i don't know
how you get from three to five without
dying press what b to get on the hood b
to get on it go now he'll go a block and
you'll be good there we go three that's
three what do i do now get five stars
without a car yep hey don't help him
beat that one don't help him beat that
one he knows how to beat that one come
on that's four stars
i died i died again at four stars i'm
gonna cry uh
how are you still here
my gosh thinking i died me i need one
more star chandler you can't do it in
the car you gotta get out give me five
stars already i'll use this until i need
the railgun no
no
what the heck how do you get the fifth i
died too
i don't want you to be all stinky
it's fair he had to be the glitter now
this is fun let's get this ball rolling
baby i gave chandler a little something
and i gave it to youtube what'd you give
them chris
i got it i got it let's go
chandler got five stars and now it's me
versus carl did you want the the special
thing that i gave everybody else
chris somehow not even competing anymore
and he's still cheating against me
oh hey i got five stars i got five
sources and i actually blew myself up
right after i got it oh
i didn't
that means carl lost he left the
building to make coral feel better you
should do the punishment with them all
right let's go call an uber this is all
your fault carl why'd you have to lose
oh
why did you have to see that's bad hurry
just one squirt
oh oops oh stop i'm sorry
it's bad for me too what did that thing
brian with 4.96 stars is on his way
oh he's here he's here he's here
hello this is my friend carl carl you're
gonna have to ride in a bed brother does
he smell that bad oh wait he's your
friend man you pit you choose man this
traffic sticks sir i smell bad take care
be safe okay thank you so much why was
he so nice we felt so bad